Uh, okay, let's go.
You know, every time I do this I'm stepping
into the lion's den, but let's go to the two
one zero area code.
We have a lot of trolls from San Antonio and
anytime I pick up on two one zero it's a risk,
but I'm doing it her from two one zero.
Who's this?
Where you calling from?
Uh, my name is Andre and yes, I'm calling
from San Antonio.
Hey, what's going on Andre?
Okay.
Uh, I have I guess two topics that I'd like
to address as you and I, and by the way, I
love you show.
Thank you.
I'm, I'm more right leaning.
Um, but I do appreciate the fact that you
put in to your work.
Sure.
Thank you.
Uh, the two topics I guess you can choose
which one you'd want to talk about are between
immigration and I get in health care.
Uh, I've done quite a bit of research on both
ends and uh,
well why don't you like one and just tell
me what your question is about it.
Okay, let's go, let's go with health care
then.
Because my question for you and health healthcare
is if you know anything about how her care
was Ron and the 20th and early 19 hundreds.
Yeah.
Well.
So there, it depends on what industry.
So we actually just did a piece about how,
um, when the sailing industry was really big,
a bigger in the United States.
Um, the founders now, this is prior to 1900,
obviously put in place a mandatory tax that
was paid for both by the ship owners and the
sailors, which was used to pay for their healthcare,
which was sort of a government mandate, uh,
for health coverage.
And then in the period between skipping ahead
World War One and World War II, the US was
going in the direction of more of a European
type system.
And Wendell potter outlines this in his book
deadly spin.
And because at a time when we weren't getting
along with Germany, it sounded a little too
much like what the Germans are doing.
It was abandoned and we ended up with the
system that we have now, which is unfortunate,
if you my perspective.
Okay.
Yeah, no, yeah.
We ended up with the worst of both worlds.
Yeah.
Uh, there was a small period of time where
there is a good amount of physician groups
where you could pretty much localize your
health care and have, you know, you know,
series of different specialties of, of doctors
that you could, you could pay for health insurance
through them and
you don't pay the doctors for health insurance
or you pay them for health care.
I'm not fully understanding
it's for health care.
It's, it's, uh, you know, directly, directly
from the doctors.
There's not a intermediary like got it.
Like there is today.
Okay.
Uh, essentially, uh, one of the, one of the
issues that I see with today's health insurance,
it's the fact that doctors are completely
unable to, uh, price of their own.
They're their own service essentially.
The insurance companies tell them how much
they're going to get paid.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I mean it's not untrue.
It's true that they are, if you're mostly,
I mean a doctor could say we are not going
to accept insurance and then they can charge
whatever they want.
And in fact, doctors have, doctors do come
up with their own book rate.
Like, for example, I know a lot of people
who work in mental health and they will say
our rate is $180 for an hour psychotherapy
session.
But for people who have say Tufts health insurance,
we've agreed to accept $98 for the hour.
Um, so it's sort of their call as to whether
they want to say we're not going to insurance.
That's 100% accurate to the way health concurrence
has done for the majority of doctors.
Uh, essentially with doctors have to do is,
is price their services higher than what they
would ever, you know, reasonably tars is a
single person because no matter what the insurance
companies are going to have reimbursement
rates based on their records.
Right.
Well, the doctor charges more getting into
some bucket.
There's two different things going on.
Part of the re it's true that the insurance
companies negotiate a lower rate and in a
sense, yes.
If a doctor says, in my example, if they say,
well, I charge $600 an hour for psychotherapy
or they charge 200 like either way, the insurance
company has an amount that they've determined
for psychiatrists, psychologists and social
workers and licensed marriage and family therapists
that they reimburse.
So part of what you're pointing to is that
in order to account for nonpayment and stuff
that gets written off, that's another element
that pushes these sort of list prices above
what any insurance company actually pays.
This is, there's many factors here.
Now, my problem is, my problem with the insurance
industry as it is today is exactly that.
I feel like the doctors don't have autonomy
in their own practices to, to cater to health
care locally, which is how healthcare is administered,
uh, to their, to their patients.
So how would you give [inaudible]
largest?
My, so let, let, let, let me finish real quick.
My largest issue with, with possibly going
into an even bigger and more, uh, controlling
single payer health care system will be, uh,
just the enlargement of that pole issue where
doctors are going are going to be target and
the ridiculous of how insurance companies
are going to be negotiating different amounts
and then all the negotiation is going to be
done on the government side with the FDA and
other things.
And we're just completely out of control,
out of control.
Yeah.
But I think, uh, I understand what you're
saying conceptually, but if you actually go
to a real single payer system, uh, that that
has significantly less importance.
Um, and we've sort of outlined why in our,
in our segments a about it.
Listen, I gotta run is very interesting what
you're bringing up.
I think you're, you're just off a little bit
in terms of some of the context, but a, this
is complicated stuff and I'm very glad that
you're thinking about it.
Let's go to one
break.
That is, it tore today.
We will take calls again very, very soon.
The David Pakman show at David Pakman Dotcom.